we begin with a major diplomatic
breakthrough with North Korea a secret
meeting just revealed to the world
CIA director Mike Pompeo met with Kim
jong-un over Easter weekend paving the
way for potential summit between
President Trump and the dictator the
president spoke about the trip and his
Secretary of State
[Music]
so I think that Mike will be in good
shape we'll see what happens he's going
to be so this is pretty high-level
Kimberley James clapper President
Obama's top Intel chief went over there
and Madeleine Albright went over there
but to have Pompeo go over there and a
secret mission is pretty big how does
the trouble administration not get
suckered into a deal like previous
administrations the Bush administration
the Clinton administration and make that
same mistake yeah I think by virtue of
the representation that was sent you
know I think Pompeo is somebody who has
you know I'm gonna speak to the nature
of quality of the past administration
but I'm saying as it relates to Pompeo
the experience he has you know with the
CIA position he's in now I think it's a
wise choice and it also shows the United
States is willing to engage in
diplomatic lines of discourse to be able
to solve complex geopolitical problems
this should be a positive for everybody
because he's saying you know what we're
taking this seriously we're putting
focus and attention on it
we're being open-minded we want to talk
to them and work out something in a good
way that is going to be beneficial not
just to the United States and North
Korea South Korea China but globally the
the world at large
put some positivity into it hopefully
he's gonna be able to make some inroads
you can't do anything unless you
fry and he's trying pretty hard and he's
negotiating from a position of strength
unlike percent other previous
administration fire and fury that's
right
data some of the other Democrats on the
Senate Intel committee are not so happy
with Mike Pompeo they may vote against
him and the white house is saying please
don't undercut him during this kind of
overture like this and we have some
sound of some Democrats explaining their
position let's listen director Pompeo
has shown a disdain for diplomacy
putting military action at a higher
priority I think he sets a poor example
in terms of American values so I will
strongly oppose his nomination at do
expect for someone who is the nominee to
be the Secretary of State when he speaks
with the committee leadership and when
he was asked specific questions about
North Korea to share some insights about
such a visit I think the diplomat that
represents this country Secretary of
State especially under this president
has to be somebody who really has a
strong orientation toward diplomacy and
not somebody who's going to exacerbate
the president's worst tendencies Dana it
takes a lot to get me worked up but I am
I am worked up about this how is it that
Blumenthal the senator from New Jersey
can say or Connecticut that that Pompeo
has a disdain for diplomacy when he
spent his Easter weekend flying to North
Korea to sit down and actually talk to
Kim jong-un which I believe is diplomacy
the president also benefits from this
being the beginning of his
administration when this is happening
for example Madeleine Albright when she
went and was at the very end like within
the last they only had two months left
and President Clinton had a choice he
could work on Middle East peace or North
Korea he chose Middle East peace that
deal fell apart and later tells
Madeleine Albright I wish I would have
gone and done the North Korea deal so
things happen president to president I
feel like the Democrats are picking a
fight that they do not want to have I
don't think they will win it it is not
sustainable to have this argument the
other thing about senator menendez being
frustrated that Pompeo didn't tell them
he's saying well that he was
forthcoming in his testimony well yeah
because he had a secret meeting to go to
North Korea and he is the CIA director
they confirmed him a year ago and to
assume that he can't be CIA directly he
can't be State Department ahead but he
can run the CIA in nine months is
preposterous to me I think that this is
a really bad example for the United
States to set for the world you don't
have to like my phone pale but you
should confirm him and let him do his
job and shouldn't Greg the Democrats be
applauding the administration for this
type of diplomatic overture of course
not how can they possibly handle this
kind of achievement from somebody that
they despise we're gonna have to truck
in thousands of therapy llamas from Peru
to deal with the mental breakdown that's
gonna happen with all of the haters who
wants so badly for Trump to fail even if
his success could mean an incredible
transformation in world and in world
safety I mean if you denuclearize North
Korea if they unite if this happens
you're gonna have to make some room on
Mount Rushmore and get the chisel out
it's it's it's it's interesting I mean
it must be hard for CNN and MSNBC
because they're too busy covering a
consensual transactional sex act that
happened years ago I mean imagine if the
CNN if CNN now we're around when the
Berlin Wall fell they would be covering
a Love Boat reunion that is how stupid
this is and by the way I think was just
a week ago or so uh we were talking
about how Comey you know said that he
compared Trump to a mafia boss and the
media was like oh this is terrible I
think we realized that a mafia boss
beats a massage therapist this is it's
not a bad thing to have somebody who
talks tough who reset the table and it
comes down to a system that we have
noticed he would Trump enters he kind of
throws the table over says everything's
changed now he takes the hardest
position and you have to walk towards
him and they understand that language
you cannot understand ambiguous
intellectual paralysis of analysis
language but you can understand that and
I think that's why this is working so
Gregg's saying he came in and he pulls
out a TPP
he puts the security deal on the table
with the South Korea
you slap sanctions on the Chinese war
games with our allies like Japan and
South Korea and it looks like things are
moving in the right direction do you
give the president any credit for any
action he's taken what what is it I was
just gonna I was waiting for you to tell
me what moved in the right direction I
mean one this is a historic summit
that's potentially but I think 60 or 70
years and that we're on the eve of a
historic summit between north and south
well let me just say it's not like you
know when you've heard this around the
table it's not like the first time
people have gone over there you said
right in the beginning that not only a
clapper gone but that our Secretary of
State Madeleine Albright had gone and
don't forget Rodman
but the problem is that the North
Koreans always say oh yeah well we'll do
something what will come along right and
maybe they say well we'll stop selling
this stuff right we'll stop selling it
to the Pakistanis and the people in the
Middle East or we'll think about maybe
not making so much but they never say
we'll give up our current you're right
arsenal of weapons right so the question
for Pompeo and I disagree with Dana
pretty strongly on this because it seems
to me Oh
has been a guy that says oh yeah first
right go right ahead right uh he
disagrees with diplomacy when it comes
not only to the climate deal but to the
Iranian deal he's gonna go to war the
climate know you spoke about him and
someone you're saying he went to North
Korea on over the Easter holiday so of
course he believes in diplomacy to the
contrary he has a history of undermining
diplomatic deals and so I think that for
people in the Senate they're saying wait
a second that's going to be your the
Iran deal the climate deal but to say
that he is going to somehow and out
isn't good just because it's a deal
sometimes deals are bad and you have to
get at it well I don't think those are
bad deals so let me say that up front
but I will say this other Americans do
but doesn't matter because it is
American polity signed the deal as the
American people that was our government
and so you can say oh you know I show up
and I'm a great deal maker so I'm gonna
bluster my way through I think a lot of
people say exactly what did Pompeo get
from his
what is the news out of that visit that
he gets some concession or is it the
case that we're giving everything to
North Korea in terms of okay no I've got
to point out that I got a point that hip
ogress here on one side he's saying
Pompeius mean for being harsh on the
climate deal and now he's being soft on
North Korea number one the climate field
everybody now agrees it was a lousy
lousy deal
it cost a hundred trillion dollars over
a century now it doesn't mean that there
isn't a dick yes I have looked at it you
have not I am right you were wrong
settling all right what my point is this
is that he actually went there right
because the presidency is regarded as
hard not soft so it changes the whole
the way this the atmosphere of it it's
not like they're gonna put I don't think
they're gonna push Trump around because
I think they've seen him bomb Syria
twice you Sarah's red lies that be
crying oh it surprises me is the
conservative point of view Dick Cheney
Don Rumsfeld said to : Powell who came
in after Albright and said you know I
would like to see if we can get some
negotiations going Dick Cheney
Don Rumsfeld said no we're not playing
ball with this guy he just wants a
meeting with the president and he'll use
it to convince his people that nuclear
devices had brought the u.s. that was
true with Korea
that was true but the calculus has
changed now that they have a nuclear
weapon they had nuclear weapons then
well they have nuclear weapons because
we've secured a number of bad deals with
them and they've cheated on everyone
what's different this time is because we
believe the sanctions have brought in
them brought them to their knees and
we've got serious gunships
encircling them the country's starving
and there's actually good progress being
made between the north and the south and
we haven't seen in decades well you so
let's just hold out hope maybe something
positive John Bolton is very skeptical
about the North Koreans right he he was
very critical of Condoleezza Rice who
was trying to also make a deal with our
allies and North Korea at the end of the
administration so he's now on board at
the National Security Council I think
that if that's the concern there at
least is somebody at the table with a
voice saying and be careful and just to
say really quickly the president
didn't undermine these deals he's the
commander in chief and he has to
evaluate them and decide what's in the
best interests the United States and
what is not and he made a calculation
the Iran deal was not and that the Paris
climate change the core deal was not as
well and then he acted prudently to
withdraw from those